ja und jetzt ein uns weitere nachrichten
wir schauen hier einmal exklusiv auf das
dorf das so sehr betroffen ist von oben
schuld in ahrweiler in rheinland pfalz
jetzt wir sitzen derzeit im helikopter
bild live im helikopter im flug über das
krisengebiet wir schauen uns das ganze
von oben an das dorf das derzeit nicht
zu erreichen sind sechs häuser sind dort
eingestürzt 70 menschen verletzt
knapp 700 einwohner hat das dorf das
bedeutet zehn prozent der einwohner sind
derzeit vermisst wir sehen hier exklusiv
diese aufnahmen jetzt von oben die
situation dieses kleinen dorf ist und
man sieht auch dort der blick von oben
es ist alles voll mit braunem wasser es
gibt dort keinen menschen kein haushalt
kein haus der besungen hier noch einmal
näher dran hier sieht man auch die
zerstörung kein haus das nicht betroffen
ist von dieser
überschwemmungskatastrophe das sind
schockierende aufnahmen aus diesem dorf
um das wir seit den frühen morgenstunden
so sehr banken heute früh gegen 6 uhr 36
kam die ersten meldungen von dort rein
wo es hieß das sind sechs häuser
eingestürzt in diesem dorf in rheinland
pfalz im landkreis ahrweiler mit seinen
ungefähr 700 einwohnern
dann haben wir dieses dorf alle auf der
karte gesucht haben geschaut wo ist das
wie kommt man dahin sind mit unseren
reportern auch haben uns auf den weg
dorthin gemacht und haben überhaupt
nicht mehr uns vorkämpfen können in
diese region das hat uns den ersten
eindruck davon vermittelt wie
schwieriges gewesen sein muss für die
einsatzkräfte auch überhaupt dorthin zu
kommen das heißt wir haben dann über
telefon versucht kontakt zu finden
dorthin haben vereinzelt stimmen aus dem
ort gehört die uns gesagt haben das ist
katastrophal ii an das mit
kriegsähnlichen zuständen
beschrieben die menschen dort und wir
wissen jetzt warum das sind die ersten
aufnahmen aus der luft von diesem ort
aus schuld in rheinland pfalz im
landkreis ahrweiler live sind sie dabei
aus dem helikopter hierbei bild live
unser kollege jörg löbker dreht in
diesem moment diese aufnahmen hier von
der ahr die normalerweise ein kleines
flüsschen ist an dieser stelle einen
bogen um dieses dorf macht aber die
dieses dorf in den letzten stunden
komplett vereinnahmt hat und dort häuser
zum einsturz gebracht hat
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren